And the falafel is sort of squished so that all of the insides and
the crunchy bits all get mixed into that bread
That is wonderful!
Good morning everyone, it's Mark Wiens with migrationology.com
in Amman Jordan, we arrive early this morning at about 5 AM from Bangkok
and then came straight to the hotel ate breakfast
and then took a nap and just woke up
It's still kind of drizzly today and overcast and it keeps drizzling every now and then
We just drove for about 15 minutes
and we're going to a restaurant called Al-Quds
which is famous in downtown Amman for serving falafel
Oh!
Jordan is known for having some of the best falafel in the Middle East
and so this place only serves falafel sandwiches and
you can choose your size of bread, I got, I'm not sure what size it is,
but it is a bun and then they're gonna fill the falafels inside of the bun
with all the different toppings and ingridients
and serve it as a sandwich and this is a popular little spot, it's only a take away
-Okay umm, this is
-Oh yeah!
-This is your first glimpse of Jordanian hospitality,
-they saw you're doing this and this is
-Oh, so they gave us same falafels not in the buns
-For you to try
-Thank you!
Right as I was saying that they don't serve falafel on its own,
they gave me some to sample on their own and so this is like the special falafel treament here
A combination of ground chickpeas and some spices then deep fried into these little patties and
-I think that is tahini, is that tahini on top?
-Yes
They look like miniature little cupcakes, they're like flat on the bottom and kinda rounded on the top
Oh that's incredible!
That blend of spices and the turmeric in there and there's like an herb
flavor to it and then it's really crispy
kinda like dry, but fluffy and moist all at the same time on the inside
That's delicious! Oh, that's really really good!
He is so fast with the falafel mixture and he puts it into a little mould
and then straight into the oil and you can just smell the aroma coming out that oil
it's incredible! We got our sandwiches now for our main course and it is
in a sesame bun you can see the bun is just loaded with sesame seeds
And the falafel is sort of squished so that all of the insides and
the crunchy bits all get mixed into that bread
There are tomatoes in here, there are pickles, there are cucumbers
and then that sauce, I believe is tahini, which is sesame paste
And I'm not sure what else there is, oh yeah, I did get it spicy so
you can see a little bit of like chili, oh yeah, there is some chili powder in there as well
Wow that's beautiful! I'm gonna try to take as big of a bite as possible to get everything in one bite
What I really love
about this sandwich just from my first bite
is there so many different crispy dimensions of texture
The bread is crisp in a baked kind of way and then the falafel is crispy in the deep fried kind of a way
I think that tahini is also really good making it nice and moist
and then the addition of the pickles, the tomato is juicy
That is wonderful!
And even those sesame seeds are really really good as well, those crispy
it tastes like crispy roasted sesame seeds on the bun
The falafel was incredible, we're now walking down rainbow street
I think we're gonna go try some Arabic ice cream next
-Yes, Gerard!
-We're going to a place called Gerard Ice Cream
-It's a local ice cream place
You can see that they have different flavours
Also all the new very popular flavours all over the world like chocolate bar flavours, nutella, snickers, kinder
you name it, but traditional ice cream is that one over there, it's called Arabic ice cream
I got a scoop of the Arabic ice cream in a cone and it comes
there's pistachios in here and the main flavouring is from Arabic gum
which is a sap from a tree
Oh what I really love are those little pieces of pistachios, little creamy pistachios
and then the flavour it's kind of like a cross between vanilla with a little hint of caramel
We're just arriving to a place called Wild Jordan, which is kind of a conservation restaurant and cafe
On the entrace floor of this place there is a handicraft store where they sell a lot of
handicrafts and art from around Jordan and this cafe also has really nice view of the city
and you can see on the opposite hill across from this cafe there is the citadel
which I think we will visit tomorrow, but we're just gonna sit here for a little while. relax, and I just ordered up a tea
That is a giant tea bag!
Another name for this tea is called Malise
Oh Yeah!
That is a very relaxing tea
I don't know what is all going on in there, but there are definitely a lot of herbs
We drove to an area of Amman called Abduon which is, Fadhi calls it the Beverly Hills of Amman
so it's a very high end area and we have stopped to the place called
the Delights Shop to try some different dates
Everything they have here are dates,
but then they are covered in a variety of different chocolates and a variety of different toppings
And this one, they have given me to try which mint with dark chocolate
and there's a date on the inside of this
Wow!
That is
really
rich and sweet
It's just tasty
on the inside and then covered in a dark chocolate and then with just a hint of a mint flavour at the end
And they gave us a little to go pack of chocolate covered dates as well
Just a very short ride from where we eat the dates
we have come to a restaurant, a local restaurant called Al Osrah
And this is a restaurant that serves just good and traditional food
we ordered just a full table of different foods, the colors and the different dishes are incredibly beautiful
One of the dishes i don't think I've ever had before is called fatteh
and it is, it's kind of a dipped paste in texture, but there is actually bread inside of it
-bread mixed with hummus and then I think this are pine nuts
-Yes
Pine nuts on top and to eat all this food I have a stack of bread,
but the actual fatteh because there is bread already included in it,
you don't need to eat it with bread you eat it more like a almost like a pudding with a spoon
Wow!
Hummus is usually more like heavy and filling,
but with the addition of that bread, that kinda soaked bread inside of the hummus
it's more light and fluffy, it's like a light and fluffy hummus
It tastes kinda like whipped hummus
And I'm gonna try this chicken liver
It's a good
idea to add different things together so
a little bit of hummus on top of this, that looks delicious! And all of that olive oil
I'm gonna add a little bit of chili sauce to finish off this bite
Oh this is a beautiful beautiful bite!
That liver, is so creamy and like soft in texture that it actually blends in to the texture of the hummus
You can taste the kind of irony richness of that liver which is really good
And then just that little bit of chili sauce just completely completes that single bite
-Take a piece of the falafel
-Oh yeah!
-Okay, go to the hummus
-And then dip
Oh one more thing, and then the chili
Oh yeah!
-That's a good bite
-That is a good idea
-Try it!
Fadhi has recommended
a combination that includes the bread
and then with the falafel in the middle
Add some hummus
Some hummus in there
And then the final addition is some of that chili sauce
All right!
This is a pickled cucumber and carrot
Wow!
That carrot is really really crisp
And then
a little bit sour and mostly salty
And this one is the ful which is mashed up fava beans
Really really good, and it has a little bit of, I think there is some lemon juice
on there you can taste like the lemon fresh taste to it
A little bit spicy, but really good flavour
To end the meal, there are some slices of  fresh lemon which is common to
use at the end of the meal just to kind of clean your mouth
I haven't eaten it yet, but Ying tried one and said it is extremely sour
so I am anticipating some serious sourness coming out of this lemon
Yeah, oh wow, it like builds with sourness, oh wow, I can immediately feel my tongue tingling
It's like a shock to the mouth
Okay, I think one piece is good enough
For our final stop this evening, we've come to a place called Tamriyeh Omar
And this is just a little closet sized shop, but it's really really well known
And this place has been here for 44 years, what they are more famous for serving here is
called a tamriyeh and it is a sweet and what he does is he takes a piece of dough
and he makes it into a huge very thin sheet and then adds in a slice
I think it's seminola cake which he adds in the middle and then presses it down into
a patty shape and then he puts that straight into the hot oil and then he
deep fries until a golden crisp and then when it's done cooking then it's transferred for it to drain and then
I think it's dusted with some powdered sugar
That's right out of the oil, it is like burning my palm right now
and so this is it, it's in like a patty shape, I'm gonna test it
Oh wow!
That is really hot and fresh and crispy
We just made it back to the hotel, thinking about going to bed pretty soon it's been a long day
and so I will see you all tomorrow on the next vlog
Thank you all very much for watching today's video please remember to give it a thumbs up if you enjoyed it
And I will see you on the next video
Good morning everyone, It's Mark Wiens with migrationology.com in Bangkok, Thailand